hello everybody hello hello i am awake guys just so you guys know i did wake up a couple of hours early because um um i went into a food coma last night so uh but yes okay before i go into my food coma story let me just say uh we are oh sorry i just got uh i'm like my brain is like all over the place because i did have a little bit of caffeine right now so my attention span might not be the very highest right now and i just got a notification from the sound team on whether or not they're here today so i was like oh message so um i can get sort of a little obvious that i did have some caffeine i had some uh gamer subs today because uh i woke up a little early and by a little early i may or may not have woken up at six in the morning uh
just a little early.
And then I was like, do I stay up?
And I'm like, maybe I should stay up.
You know what?
Maybe I should stay up a little.
And if I feel a little tired, then I'll have some gamer subs.
And by the way, did you guys know I have a gamer sub code?
And if you use the code Doki Bird, you can get like, I don't know, some percentage off.
I don't even remember.
I have so many codes.
getting harder to remember what the codes are and what percentage it is hashtag ad anyway so i am i got a little bit into a food coma because um i wanted to have a hot pot last night um and you'll be like wow dokey having hot pot all by yourself no no no okay so if you guys didn't know there's some hot pot places where you get your very own pot like so for those who are alone and have no friends this is the place for you um so yeah so they give you like their very own pot um and it's like not a giant ass pot and then like but then you're like oh but doki what about like the the the toppings like the the meat selection all that shit don't won't you can't even like order a lot of it because you can't eat all of it by yourself well jokes on you because they thought of that too uh for us for those who just really want to eat hot pot but like they have to eat alone okay uh so they have this special there's this like there's like there's like a lot of these there's a lot of hot pot places
like this now because they're like wait some people actually want to just eat hot pot and like they may or may not have not have friends but it's not because they don't have friends is that maybe they just want to eat alone like can so can we just not want to eat alone like like we don't want to do any socialization and we just want to go there get some good ass food talk to nobody and then watch tea like watch your fucking show on your phone prop your phone up against like your bottle of water and just watch some show while you're eating hot pot can i just not have that anyway uh anyway um so there is some places um where they're like wow there is like an audience for that you know they're they're they're like customers that you know want to eat hot pot but they just want to eat alone so there's these hot pot places where you get your own pot and then there's like there's like like they put up all these toppings and meat selection and veggies um in like this aisle so like you know
like like a salad bar it's a hot pot bar
blaming me.
Like, I know there's some of you guys who have the same thoughts as me.
It was like, thank God I can eat by myself.
Okay, anyway, I can eat hot pot by myself.
So it's like a little buffet selection, but for like hot pot, like toppings, you know.
So like they give you a pot, and then you just like, you know, you don't have to grab like, you know, they don't give you a whole giant plate of meat.
You can be like, I'll take two pieces of lamb and then one piece of and like oh the noodles and everything and then you put it in your pot and then they give you like um but you're so defensive anyway um um and then um and then you just go to the cashier and they like they do it by weight so they charge it by weight so like how heavy your pot is which is really nice because like some of the some it's not buffet they charge your pot they they just do know you get like very expensive fucking toppings but it doesn't matter because they just charge it by weight um and then like and then like and then you can choose the broth you want so you know that's really good so you'd be like i want this broth and then you give you a number and they'll take it to you and so so you know it was my first time trying it because i was like wait it's like okay to be fair i um i did try it there was i i had a little bit of trauma a couple of years ago because i places uh but they didn't have the hot pot
selection thing um they just gave you like at that time they had like like it was like a solo hot pot but like you couldn't really pick the toppings you wanted um and um I threw up like like after I came home so then I got a little trauma about eating a hot pot alone because I'm like oh did I just not cook it right like yeah and then you have to cook it yourself too like they use a miniature hot pot but then you have to cook it yourself so I had like a little bit of a trauma because I was like oh no like did I not do it correctly like like is it like when I'm by myself I just don't know how to do hot pot by myself like so so I I was like I was just like all right let's do this again but like I had a different restaurant um and this time you choose your toppings and then they cook everything for you which is also very nice too so you choose the toppings and then oh yeah i think i ate too much it could have been i ate too much i don't remember i just remember i told my friend i was gonna
go to this place and then my friend was like um uh my friend was like oh you ate too much didn't you and i think i ate too much i must have like um put too much meat or something because i was like i have to finish it because the the one i went to a couple years ago I they didn't have to choose your topping shit so they gave me a lot for the solo thing now I'm remembering sorry I'm remembering my trauma now I'm digging through my trauma um but this time now I realized oh I can pick how much I want like this time like this time around I can actually pick how much meat I want and like I didn't pick any veggies I obviously because I because I'm a child um so I only got the the mushrooms the anoki mushrooms because that's the only veggies that's inside my body.
So, I don't know, I just don't like wet cabbage.
It just fucking tastes weird.
I don't know.
Me personally, it's just, I don't know.
Wet cabbage just tastes really weird.
I just can't handle that.
And then, you know, I just, you know, got everything and it was so good.
Oh my God.
And then they cook everything for you too.
So you know, you pick the toppings, you, you know, pay for the pot and then they cook everything for you.
And I was like, yum, yum.
Mama likey Sorry I have caffeine in my stomach right now I don't have any filters I'm tired But I'm like I just have adrenaline in my system I'm sad
Just laughing Anyway So after that I went into a I went into a uh uh food coma right i know it's like unwise to you know go to sleep right after you ate food because of like um what's it called the the acid from your throat i know there's a word for it but i can't remember recall it on the top of my head um let's say citric acid but that's just lemon like what is it called when you have like the acid acid reflex yeah uh i don't know why it's like citric acid reflux yeah like so um that i was i luckily for some reason i guess my stomach was like super happy about the hot pot and it's like today we give you get one pass like you get a pass for today i am satisfied so um um so like i woke up and i didn't get acid reflux so Thank fucking God,
like, happy belly was just like, you get a pass for today.
So, yeah, that's why I woke up at, like, I guess, like 6 to 7 in the morning.
I did some bits of work.
That is just, that's been, like, sleeping next.
To be fair, it's also because he's not allowed in my room, because I haven't cleaned my room yet.
Because, like I said, what I did was when I got home, I should really fix that.
But, like, I've been so fucking busy ever since I came back.
and so like for those who weren't uh for those who like uh weren't there like for my first stream back um basically what happened was like uh i left my bed with like my luggage stuff that i took out from when i was in went to the guanjo trip for arrivals and i just like put everything on my bed and then to like repack my suitcase and then when i got home um you know my bed was filled with stuff like like clothes um stuff i bought in guanjo um everything and what i did was i took my arm out and i did like the sweep to the floor because i was so tired i just wanted to sleep
my arms and then i just sweeped everything onto the floor and then i went to bed and it's sort of And also my suitcase is also just like there.
And then I haven't closed.
And I didn't close my suitcase.
So I was just like, there's no mud.
There's literally just like random junk.
Like not junk, but like, you know, souvenirs.
Souvenirs, clothes, all that stuff.
And then I haven't fixed it yet.
So, um, so, uh, look, it's just my bedroom right now.
Like I sort of, I cleaned everything.
It's just my, okay.
That's a lie.
I didn't clean everything else, but I cleaned a lot.
Okay.
Um, anyway, so I even cleaned my keyboard.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, so, um, it was so bad.
Like, I want, you know, like, okay, I will let you guys know that I shed hair a lot.
And I think it's not helping when, you know, when you're more stressed out, the more hair you stress that you shed.
But also I have a lot of hair.
So, um, so when I was like, I'm going to finally clean my keyboard because I didn't clean it for a while.
now um only because I kept thinking that um um I was gonna get the um the I was waiting for the second the second the version to wooden keyboard um so I was waiting for that and I was waiting oh my gosh I hope my hair is okay actually I don't even know I hope I hope my hair is like because I've been very stressed out like the last couple of months so I hope I'm not I'm not fucking up my hair.
Anyway, you know, obviously, if you had never clean your keyboard, by the way, you should clean your keyboard.
Don't do what I did.
It was so fucking bad.
You know, I took the key caps off, and then I rinsed it in a bowl.
And then there was a lot of hair underneath the key caps.
And I was just like, how did all this hair get there?
I was like, it was so disgusting.
I was like, how did all that hair get into my keyboard?
I it was it was really fucked up.
So but clean your keyboard don't do what I do just be it on that.
So, um, um, it was really bad it was really bad like you have to clean you also have to clean your keycaps, um, like in a bowl of water with soap and everything.
I had like soak in there for a while before I, um, before I had to, um, to like, you know, dry it and everything.
so yeah and then i cleaned the board itself um so yeah no you you should and i even bought the little slime thing where you used to um where you used you know the slime thing and so i used some of that and also like getting a q-tip with alcohol all that fucking shit you know how you normally clean a keyboard um but it was a whole hour plus adventure that's no it was it was a Life's no it was not a waste of money.
That's how bad the keyboard was.
It was it was absolutely It was I thank God that yeah, it was a deep deep clean.
No, I had to use the slime to start the clean Because there was no way I was gonna start the clean with the q-tips.
It was that bad.
I had to do the Like take the the you know how you have to layer it, you know when you're like in larynx there was layers to break the layer before i go in with with the with the q-tip um
i'm sorry i know it's gross but welcome to the real world look at your key i swear to you guys look at your own cleat keyboard you gotta clean that guys yeah look at look at your own clean keyboards guys and like don't tell me like you gotta clean your own keyboards too guys um um anyway anyway so so see i told i told you i was getting my life together so that's why anyway i said all of that um and that's why um that's not allowed in my uh in my oh my i guess clean it regularly guys freaking freaks you're like where the freak who the fuck cleans their keyboard regularly who the fuck has the time for that you freaks
um me um anyway that's not that at the moment isn't allowed in my room just like i said there's a stuff on the floor and i don't i'm worried that he's gonna you know get in i don't know i feel like he's gonna kidnap something from my room and i i'm really worried i don't want to like like i don't i'm really worried that he'll like accidentally consume something because there's a lot of stuff on the floor right now um but don't worry i will eventually clean that room um this week i promise you guys that uh i i swear to god it will happen uh eventually this week by by this week it will happen also meddy they give the super chat thank you thank you the chef realizing this is the fourth time you came to it's my first time there it's my very first time there guys um thank you the super chat thank you thank you uh yakov thank you the super chat thank you thank you a hot pot place where they cook it for you is that really hot pot though or is it just soup with extra steps thank you for the
super chat thank you yes it is hot pot because the pot is hot like it's self-explanatory it's not like it's a cold pot look these you expect a hot pot to have a hot pot like there's nothing else to it like thank you in the super chat thank you thank you and what if i'm just i had a bit i worked so hard okay sometimes i want someone else to cook it for me But I am alone.
And if I have to pay someone else to pay to cook, I will.
Because I am tired.
And I don't want to wait like 30 seconds to five minutes depending on what the meat is.
Pat your ass is.
I just want to eat the meat now.
I don't want to wait.
Paturesson, thank you for the super chat.
Also, the fact that noodles take like five minutes?
Fuck that shit.
I'll get to eat my noodles now.
Anyway, Paturesson, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why you order a special chef?
Boy, not eat vegetable.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Yes, it is.
It feels like five hours.
okay worst part is like you put the noodles in and then you just gotta wait five like and you stare at the noodles and wait like you have to send it but then you're like has it been five minutes i don't fucking know like i have to stare at the noodles and just instead i get the pot and everything's cooked and then i'd be like yum yum like there you go i don't have to stare at the
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just get married and you'll have someone cooking all the hot pot you could ever want.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Anyway, guys.
Now onto the dokey jam.
Sorry.
I had to have my daily rant of the day to stay.
as a human be as a real human being
anyway um so the joki jam i'm sorry i took a long time to uh announce the winners for the joki jam or do another joki jam stream i didn't want to like half ass the part two of the stream i know we had technically it's part three but part two the last one did not really count um because we pivoted very hard to something else um but uh i didn't want to like have acid because i wanted to you know have the time to play the games and everything um and my schedule was incredibly packed it was like the last couple of weeks you know i was all over the place i was traveling a lot i also took like a little break and stuff because i was like a little really burnt out and everything so i didn't want to like you know and then there were like i think like two to three weeks where i didn't really have a schedule so i wanted the dokey jam to be like scheduled and everything um um um so that people can like you know be like oh she's gonna do that stream i gotta make sure i'll be there if you're like
one of the devs and or something and um so that's why i took a while um i do want to do like a little disclaimer um um majority that word picked was done through a judge panel.
So I didn't pick these winners for some of them, only because I felt like it wasn't fair due to my biases, because I wasn't able to play all the games.
So I felt like it's not fair for me to personally pick a winner, just because I didn't play all the games.
And what if this one game that I didn't play might have been a better game that um that might have should have been placed higher or something so so this was picked some of the winners were picked by a judge panel um that played all the games and like had they're all like like you know they all talked and been like gave feedback on like which they feel like uh that's why it's also take a little took a little bit of time because there were 238 entries so there was a judge panel that uh picked uh um that helped picked the finalist um just because like i said i felt like there would be a bias with me picking it um only because like i said i didn't get to play all the games um so some of these winners um i would be playing them on stream as well like uh experiencing the game um with you guys uh for to be like oh these are the reasons why the judge panel um um yeah they from what i'm told they played all the games to make their decision so and they also wrote a little summary as to why it
was picked and everything for me um so yeah uh so it was very hard to decide how to pick the winners so um we had like a little back and forth because you know um you dragoons also had your own pick for what you guys think should have been the top 10 of the games.
And obviously, you know, a lot of you guys play these games and a lot of you guys voted on it as well.
But then we also were thinking, like, what about like some games?
Maybe they deserve a higher rating, like from us personally and the judges personally.
So, and we did think like, oh, yeah, maybe we should give Chad to some of the games that might not have been top 10 but we felt like where we felt like because of like you made me they didn't get a lot of people rating it or like not a lot of people played that game because it was an average of the the score it was based on the average of ratings so maybe they had a lot of people playing it and the average of the rating brought it down because there's so many different opinions and stuff like that so um that we had to take a lot of that into account because obviously like I said like some games had like like 70 ratings um some had 30 and then some of the games was like a lot of ratings their average got brought down a lot more so we took into that account as well and that's why it was very difficult because um um so yeah Like I said,
some games just didn't have enough ratings.
Or some games just had a lot of ratings.
And so we had to figure out how to balance that.
So there was a lot of back and forth with me and the team or the head project leader on how to do this.
So basically, after a lot of discussion, we decided that also before I begin, the prize pool, have six, we, six people will get prizes in terms of like, uh, it'll be top six.
Um, and, uh, it's like first place is $2,000, I believe.
Let me look at back.
Let me look back.
It is first place gets $2,000.
Second place gets a thousand.
Third place gets 500.
And then third, fourth, fifth, and
each team gets 500 and it's split between the teams um itself so it's not like each person gets a thousand like 2000 it's the entire team will get two thousand dollars um so like that's how the prize money is split and everyone that participates gets a participation prize so the sum of the devs have i know like some devs have opted out of the physical participation prize um there are two physical participation prize i'll show it on screen for those who forgot about them because before but i believe you get a um a postcard which is this this would be the postcard um and because like you know some devs didn't want to uh give their address which is understandable because of privacy you know and then also a little sticker so um so every developer that participated um gets these bonus items as a participation prize like you might not have won but you get a little like a momento for uh being part of the dokey jam so they get the little sticker and the postcard um some people opted out and
they just they would get like a uh they would also get a uh for those who opted out of the participation prize physical prizes uh we give them like a little coupon code at the uh at the dokey merch store so we also have uh that as well um so there that is uh the participation prize so anyway the winners it was very hard choice and how like i said to structure um to how we do the winners but like we talked and then some of the judges agreed that you know um they sort of deserve the placements for this so um we decided that All right,
let me show this real quick.
We decided that first, second, and third will be the official first, second, and third placements.
And I did play these three games and they were all very well done.
So, yay!
So congratulations to the Dokey Break Time Terminal devs, the one bullet.
devs and the Tamadoki devs for winning first, second, and third place.
Yay!
Congratulations!
So yes, we had a long discussion because like, you know, do we get, do we get choose new winners for first, second, third, or do we go with the ratings, the overall ratings that you guys picked?
And, you know, like I said, the judges played all the games and they all agree that first second third um should go to them um um and that you know uh um they agreed with the placement now for fourth fifth and six as i don't want to say like you know i don't want me guys to feel bad because there are like you know games that did were fourth fifth and six but um we talked for a while like i said this was very hard it was very hard because you know i wish i could have included more winners i really did um but we wanted to give a little spotlight to some games that they felt um should also deserve like recognition so i will like give a shout out to the 456 that you guys voted so there's uh dokey's flock and roll adventure the save the main and um the dokey boom dash i want to give a shout out to you guys because you guys did make um four fifth and six through the um through the user votes um but like I said the judges and I we talked and um we thought that we should highlight um the other
uh some other games that might not have made a top 10 or we're in top 10 but we're not like you know first second third um um that we want to give a highlight to and uh and like you know they played all the games um to make this judgment and um and i want to say uh i trust them in the judgment and like i said i didn't i personally didn't pick four fifth and six only because like i said i didn't have the time to play 238 games so i felt like it wasn't my place to pick the games as some because i would have biases so i will be playing for the fourth fifth and sixth place with you guys um and also I wanted to experience like playing the games live as well so like on stream as well and like showcasing it on stream like blind too so I wanted to have that opportunity as well so anyway for fourth place uh let me look over the sheet that they gave me um we have like a little this like a little summary of why it was chosen and everything so let me look through that the right one so i believe it
is it where is it all right so well and i'll go with sixth place first let me see i can find it where is sixth place all right in sixth place i know that you know we're it's for second third there's so many good games it was such a hard pick um there's you guys talented um I I really I'm so thankful to have such an amazing fan base um and such talented like fans like you guys are so talented like game programming and it's like a jam too a game jam so yes you guys had to do it all within a fucking deadline too so like you know programming art music um I guess sound effects and everything is just crazy that you guys were able to do all that like as well um do it all within like two weeks as well so i really appreciate you guys give yourself a little round of applause yippee i would love to host more of these like events for you guys showcase all your talents and everything because like you know you guys are all so talented as well and uh you guys all like united under this talent unlike
um in support of me so yippee um anyway Um, in sixth place, um, the judges have picked Doki Pop Fever.
I was like, Thedier.
So, huge congratulations to Doki Pop Fever for getting sixth place.
Um, let's see.
Uh, let's see what they wrote for the judges wrote.
So, the reason they picked Doki Pop Fever for sixth place is that they think that this game takes the fruit-fruit-combiner genre and puts an entirely new spin on it.
So the gems theme is more than represented and has quite a good polish.
So the main reason is why the judges picked this game to be mentioned to be sixth place is because they felt like the theme was chain reactions and they felt like this game highlighted the theme very, very well.
So it does um so uh that is why um it was picked uh so yeah i'm super excited to try this game out uh like later on when after i announced the other two winners in fifth place let me let me grab make sure i'm showcasing the correct one in fifth place also need to make sure that
I am showing the correct one.
It's not the fourth place one that I'm showing.
And I'm saying the correct name.
It is Sulfur and Feathers.
Oh, this is like a 3D game too.
So the reason why the judges picked this one in fifth place is because it perfectly embodies the chaotic nature of chain reactions and dragoons.
The game has a decent playtime for a relatively short development period and really shines through overall game view.
So here are some of the devs that have worked on this.
There is Junot, Lestie, Pikachu, and Dr. Danez that worked on sulfur and feathers.
Also, I believe Alan worked on the game that was sixth place.
There's no BGM because I just realized that.
We'll have BGM later when we play the games, guys.
Yay, congratulations.
Also, by the way, my sound team was like, we can only be there for the first hour, and I have yet to play any of the games, so I'm sorry.
The red was, the hot pot red was very important.
But yes, we will be playing this later on as well.
Anyway, so we might have to promote one of the regular.
mods to be temporary sound guy after that hour is gone um anyway so congratulations to the developers work uh sulfur and feathers um i don't know volume is pretty um all right finally in fourth place we have uh drum roll please in the fourth place We have,
okay, you guys can't see the title, but I can't fix this because I'm trying.
It's called Document Save the Golden Dragoon.
So you guys can see here is, here are the graphics of that game.
So the reason why the judges picked this game as fourth place, it is a Mario Maker type game that amazed us with how fast but coherent it was put together.
reactions theme perfectly and was an overall joy to play through while it didn't have a grand noise story it made up for it in creativity and interpreting the themes jams theme in its own way um so yes all the judges did look into like each criteria as well so and they wanted to focus on the theming of it um during like the judging period so i'm really looking forward to playing this game as well um the judges love the chain reactions i mean it was the theme of the game jam so um it does make sense that they were looking at how create how people interpret um interpret the uh the game like interpret that into their game design um so yes huge congratulations like i said to all the winners i'm really sorry that we couldn't pick more winners but i will definitely host more game jams in the future because it was very fun maybe i'll ask if maybe we'll collab with other vtubers and hosting a game jam too um but thank you all for uh thank you to all the devs um for participating thank you to
all the dragoons for working so hard on this doki jam the very first one too i do hope um i guys have a lot of fun playing the games um let me actually link so for anyone that wants to try out the games themselves here is the link for everyone and also like check out the results um of all the games um that were submitted um i linked it in the chat guys or you can click the link in the description too anyway let us try dokey pop fever that downloaded or is it on the web i just gotta make sure uh playing browser okay i just gotta be sure if it I have to download it or anything.
All right, let me zoom.
Zoom in.
All right.
Let's try out Doki Pop FIBA.
All right, Sound Guy.
We have, okay, we have 15 minutes.
Okay, that's good.
The sound team can be there for 15 minutes before they leave.
All right.
Check it out.
Oh.
I was not expecting that.
I thought I was playing.
it like not there all right oh okay wait does that mean i can like zoom out i don't even know they sent me the they sent me the alice in wonderland the white rabbit like like tapping the clock like tick tock the one game that's gonna be sound balanced tick tock
I'm working so hard
All right, I'm going to make sure, like, okay
Why did it not show?
Give me a sec.
Oh, there we go.
Dokey pop fever.
There we go.
All right.
Let's get credits real quick.
Oh, sorry.
I guess we're not looking at credits.
Yay, that's me.
And look how it doesn't show like them.
It's just, look, there's me, Donkey Bird.
Dad.
Oh my God, that's me.
Oh my, anyway, you see, at least there are Twitter adults.
There's Zephyr Sona for audio.
Okay, I'll say audio, Zephyr Sona, Malia and Dino too.
Programming.
Alan, Katz and Dino.
Okay, there you guys go.
It's me!
I'm in the credits!
Alright, story mode.
Alright.
Oh my god, it's the old wizard.
The grand wizard.
Alright.
Click and drag to connect doki pops together.
You can also quickly left click to pop them without connecting You can chain any dokey pop to the tomato in the middle Allowing to reach dokey pops to the other side dokey pops that change together will grow in size Once they reach 10 they'll pop on their own after one second So it's like be jeweled with swika When you you don't need to read the top it literally just says dokey pop fever mechanics just see we just need to look at the bottom
When you pop Doki Pops, nearby pieces will grow in size.
Doki Pops grown in this way can also be popped on their own.
Potentially triggering a chain reaction of pops.
Both you and your opponents have a red HP bar and a yellow SP bar.
Pop Doki Pops to keep your HP up and fill up your SP.
What does the SP do?
Opponent HP will go down when we pop Doki Pops and their SP bar will be filled over time.
When their SP bar is filled, their skill will act always.
It's my skill points.
To avoid being overwhelmed.
Press space bar to activate Doki's skill.
Throwing a Doki blade.
Oh, it's the Doki blade across the board.
Also, by the way, the ending screen is going to be different.
Across the board to increase the size.
So, you got to stay.
You got to stay for the ending screen.
For something special.
The path the night goes will follow your...
Also, it'll follow my cursor.
Increase the size.
The Doki Blade will also destroy enemy skill Doki Pops.
Try using your skill to take care of those pesky pieces on your board.
Okay.
I figured it out.
Hello.
Where are they called when they're like...
Oh!
Wait, the BGM!
Wait, what is this?
Oh!
Fast.
Alright.
Okay, we got our music in.
Step, step.
It's the wizard.
gosh darn it that old bird he's calling this early he's definitely up to no good wait what's this oh it's the eye okay cutscene joint oh it's like old bird you've called what is it this time hello grand wizard say your skill will drop there they become wizards at 30 right uh will drop onto the board oh the egg bombs will start turning red and explode after a few seconds destroying any doki pops around them uh doki pops destroyed this way do not deal damage to the sage nor do they heal you try directing your skill at them or utilizing your own pops to destroy them first sage will skill will drop egg bot away oh wait the all right let's get that up All right,
I'm ready.
All right.
Does he, like, do it after me?
Is he gonna pop?
Oh, my God.
I can't hesitate.
Can I pop his stuff?
Oh, my God.
I don't know if me popping his stuff was the right idea.
I'm gonna do it.
Okay, maybe I shouldn't have done it.
Okay.
That's okay.
All right.
Maybe I don't know I'm like thinking was that a good idea like I'm just helping him like Oh my god, don't do well under pressure.
Don't you don't do well under pressure.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh Where is where is more pops?
Okay, there's one over here uh and then there's this uh do i have do i have knife yet where's my knife where's the dokey blade oh use the middle oh what happened what oh my god did he pop them all oh wait that's yours i keep i keep popping the grand wizard i can't help it it's just there okay there you go wait he used i okay there that's right that's not me now oh my god oh my god i helped him i why do i keep helping him i can't i'm just so helpful i can't help it why does he have so many okay oh i can pop any oh oh it's because like okay okay i just realized i've been so fast okay um okay i can pop any i don't know i just see his face i'm like am i supposed to pop it i can't tell okay now that i know that i can pop yours as well it's over for you old man it's over um oh this is bad oh this is bad okay he's just stealing my score i earned this score
okay there we go jesus oh my god wait did i pop it did i pop it for him or did i pop it for me i guess i'll never know i know my hp is not okay right now it is not okay r score um there you go guys i don't think i'm very good at this game It's just a game theory.
It's just...
It's just a little game theory.
Okay.
Alright.
There we go.
That's a lot of pops that I did.
Did it help me?
I did a lot.
Oh, well, I don't know.
I guess we'll find out.
Okay.
Oh my god, stop, stop popping No I'll just keep popping I'm still alive I don't know how I'm still
Okay, I figured it out I figured out how to play this game I figured, I just realized I didn't pop My bubbles When the whole idea is that I gotta pop it.
I realized that that might have been like, oh my God, he popped my bubbles again.
He keeps doing it.
I don't know how he keeps doing it.
Like, okay.
Now I realize I was missing one important feature.
And that was, I had to pop that balloon.
But I wasn't popping it.
that's a little awkward i was just making bubbles for him to pop there you go see guys i figured how to play this game i figured it out it only took me losing the tutorial one very important detail all right it's just a little oopsie you know okay i got my knife i'm so glad we lowered the difficulty
process it but i did it i figured it out all right pop um pop
all right oh he popped that oh all right there you go see guys i'm winning now i just forgot like one very key idea about popping i had to pop which i sort of forgot to do It was a very important detail, apparently, in this game.
You could say that it might be, like, the whole premise of Doki Pop.
Uh-oh.
I just kept connecting things instead.
Who would have thought?
Oh, so that's why he was winning.
He just kept...
He was just popping my things.
Alright.
Pop, pop.
Pop.
That's right, it's over for you, Grand Wizard.
Pop!
Alright, then.
Keep popping.
We never stop.
Pop, pop!
Like my favorite community member says.
Hope he's okay.
Still haven't got our movie yet.
I hope he'll be in the movie.
Alright.
This way.
And then...
How is he still not dead yet?
At least he should have died from old age at this point.
With how long it's taking me to play this game?
Like...
He's a one-man pie true.
Look at him!
He can't even open his eyes anymore!
Like, someone, take him to a home!
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Big Minto.
There you go.
Dry ass mint.
Okay, this is where he dies.
I'm going to use my special skill.
No mercy.
That's right.
I didn't have to use my skill.
But I want the real victory.
all right bring up overall okay sound guy had one last one last um note before they had to leave um all right anyway what what what mod is still here which mod is still here guys um congratulations you've been promoted young master dokey you have finished huh you have prevailed against peril and your hard work leads you to your rightfully bountiful rewards your lesson only ends here congratulations here please enjoy what's this my bountiful reward you call it that yes master yes congratulations on your promotion um it's the same um you don't get like an actual increase in anything else regarding pay or anything uh but you know congratulations you just have more stuff to do uh young master there is no doubt that you will one day be the the dokey pop champion of the dokey land um it's dokey land i'm sorry i just have one little correction for you um for your next patch
not Doki Land.
Like, we are not affiliated with Doki Land.
You're one of the few to endure the trials.
But the road has not ended.
Young Master, I simply request you to commit.
Of course I'll come.
Wow, that's a good one.
Looks like you've learned something too.
I suppose so, young Master.
I have learned a thing or two as well.
Yeah, not bad for an old bird.
My sincerest thanks.
I'm glad to have lightened the moon now.
Wait, are you going to die?
Leave to where?
The land of my ancestors.
To the land I was born.
I am old, young master.
I wish you to rest close to those who have raised me.
Oh my god, he's got a Kung Fu Panda, this shit.
I've called to set you on your next journey, but also to bid you farewell.
So, I won't be able to meet you anymore?
Who am I to decide fate, young master?
We may, or we may not.
Life works in mysterious ways.
People come and go as unfortunately as it is.
There is a meaning to what you feel, and therefore, it is important.
but we may let myself give you one last lesson I want you to use donkey pop to connect to connect people young master to connect people yuck yes to connect to give a part of you as a gift to another for me I have shared my knowledge with you that is is all I have to say.
Once again, congratulations.
Oh, he just gave me a strand of his hair.
Is that, like...
Freak behavior?
He said technically he gave a strand of his hair in me.
Using Jokie Pop to connect?
But Jokie Pop to connect.
is about beating the enemy a weapon to connect huh you're funny old bird dead wait you can you can talk
hey doky i want us wondering if you need some help with the doky pop Championship.
What do I just don't even understand?
It's like the whole Stewie situation.
Like does does she actually understand what he's saying?
Like he's just like like he thinks he's talking but he's like oh my wow wow wow I know a person that can help you get better.
I think you said something about tribe and the local hero.
Ducky.
Oh yeah I knew it.
Oh dad.
I knew it.
I was like, why the fuck?
You can fucking talk?
Too tight.
Were you up to dead?
Oh, right.
I know a person that can help you in your dokey pop championship.
I'm sure you'll win it with help for... Oh, ring, ring, ring, ring.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot to attend this meeting.
Sorry, Dad.
Talk to you later.
Goodbye.
Good.
Goodbye?
Wolf, wolf, translation, no, wolf means kick-kaku.
I'll get it one day.
I'll get it.
Just watch me, Doki.
Oh, wait.
Am I fighting her next?
All right.
Surely our two half brain cells can get in.
We'll have the match of the century.
Can't believe I got distracted.
That old.
bird that I missed my meaning.
prepare yourself.
I'm here to fight you.
Alright.
Pop, pop.
Mint skill spawns in whips that make Joki pops around them.
Mint Joki pops are unaffected by this.
Make big Joki pops near the whips to destroy them.
Try saving Mint Joki... Mint Joki pops to take care of the whips.
Mint skill spawns in whips that makes... Okay, wait, that's her skill.
Alright.
Alright, we got this.
We can beat her.
We have the same size brain cell.
She can't be smarter than me.
Alright.
Okay.
Oops, I forgot to pop this.
That's right.
Can't pop mine.
I'll pop this net first.
I'll save.
Oh my gosh.
I forgot I can't save them.
Because, like, she'll just...
She'll just pop it.
That's fine.
I'll pop yours first.
What you're gonna do when I pop it first?
Oh, okay.
Pop this.
And now I got rid of...
That's right!
Good body or whisk!
We're dead now!
They're double dead!
Uh...
Alright, I got this.
And now pop that.
And then...
Oh god, they made it.
Tiny.
Oh my god.
We're evenly matched.
Because we're both stupid as hell, I guess.
We're evenly matched, everyone.
Oh god.
I gotta keep popping these.
Alright.
You can pop this.
Wait, that wizard didn't die?
Oh my god.
I thought it would die.
Oh my god, they're so tiny.
Wow.
Okay, I'm winning currently.
I think I am.
No hesitation.
Oh my god, she's spawning so many of them too.
Um.
Fuck.
Trying to...
Oh my god, there's so many.
Oh, they're so tiny!
She made them so tiny!
Oh!
Oh my god, it just keeps shrinking.
I'm thinking.
Oh my god, why does my HP keep going down?
There's nothing to pop.
It's actually...
Okay.
There we go.
Uh...
Okay, I have a knife.
The brains that went to her.
Okay.
Oh my god, that barely did anything.
That's how fucked up it is right now.
Oh my god.
She's just...
She just keeps sending more!
Okay.
Oh my god.
There's too many!
We have a problem!
Okay.
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
This is so bad.
No, why did it pop that?
I needed this to save my life!
Oh my god.
It's not fair.
Please nerf.
her please why is her her skill is so I want her skill swap skills I want to swap skills I I demand that we swap skills I just think that her that her ability is too OP So, like, to make this fair, I feel like that we gotta swap skills.
We got...
I had Nerfer again!
I demand a double nerf.
Oh, my God.
I said, like, does she pop it herself?
Alright, it's not fair.
She's too strong.
wait please fix her or just give me her I want her skill honestly at this point I deserve to have her ability all right there you go and she does it oh my god you bitch bitch okay all right Do I connect this and then oh my god.
She took my path.
That was I set it up.
I set that up.
Okay All right Oh, I wanted to That was my setup I set that up fair and square
Okay Is that big enough I can't tell Yeah, that should be big enough there you go
uh all right we gotta get okay if she pops this i swear to god this is not yours to pop okay mom expando these guys okay not you okay i'll just take this out okay i'll just take that okay what do you mean you get to use your special stupid power again what that didn't pop That should have popped it.
I'm just going to pop this and then do that and then pop that.
And then there you go.
There.
There we go.
Oh my god, I was going to say I swear to you guys, if that, like, turned into a tiny.
I got a lock in.
There we go.
That got rid of three.
See, look at that.
I'm popping.
We're popping.
You know how to pop.
It's over.
It's over for her.
We're figuring it out.
And then...
Get rid of this, though.
Are you serious?
Okay, we gotta use the knife.
My turn!
Oh my god.
That's not what I wanted, but okay.
Oh,
that doesn't get rid of it.
It's fine.
I got this.
All right.
It's fine.
I got this, too.
And now pop that before you pop me.
Now do that.
And then that didn't pop it.
Okay.
That's fine.
We don't care.
That should have popped it, though.
That 100% should have popped it.
Oh my gosh, she's hanging by the thread, and she knows.
What?
Okay.
That should have my pop.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
You don't need it.
Okay, uh...
There you go.
It's fine.
I took her pops.
She does nothing without it.
Okay.
we have knife no no no you fucker no okay that's good that's good that's good all right that's fine that's fine it worked out it worked out it worked out
you need to up your game i'm gonna make look i won i won sure okay next patch i want her ability i don't care if it doesn't make sense i I demand to have her ability next patch.
I want the Doki patch where I can have her ability.
Ah!
Yeah!
How'd you get so strong?
Why would I tell you?
That's not fair!
That's not fair.
What's not fair?
Come on, as a friend, please!
Yeah, you know, next Doki patch.
She doesn't even deserve an ability.
Give her zero abilities.
And then, like, when I fight her, I use her ability.
Fine, fine.
The secret to how I get so good at it is...
It's because I commit.
Commit.
Commit what?
Commit my boss.
Whoa!
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
I'll remember that.
Keep your secret.
I'll find my own way.
Got him.
Good luck.
What's this?
What should I do now?
At this point, I'll lose again.
Looks like Omere gets a special ticket to your concert this year.
Dad!
Do you seek power?
Huh?
I can help you defeat her and get the ticket you desire.
You trade her!
What?
No, you weirdo.
Whatever.
This is my card.
If you truly want to become...
He's like Darth Vader or some shit.
He's like Emperor Papadine.
Do it.
You know who to call.
Ghostbusters!
Do it.
Alright.
No, absolutely not.
We're not going to Doki Pop Island.
What?
Why?
That place is dangerous!
Is that a challenge?
You're not really taking this seriously.
Doki Pop Island is guarded by the Doki Pop Golems.
You won't survive a single second out there.
Is that a challenge?
No, it's not.
You're going to die.
Oh, that is a challenge, all right.
Your mom is a challenge.
Oh, pew, pew.
All right.
Do B skill summons a train that would chug through the top or bottom corner of your boy.
Doggy pops that run over become smaller.
Example of a train running through the bottom corner.
Oh, my God.
She shrinks everything.
Wait, that's so OP.
Let's get a blade.
I should be able to, like, get stronger.
Like, every time I win, I should be able to get, like, stronger.
And to steal their abilities.
That should be, like, a thing.
Wait, she has her ability now?
Okay, that's okay.
that side, so that's fine.
I mean, that's fine.
I actually didn't expand it, too.
As long as we're okay.
Pop pop.
Oh, wait.
There's so many doobies here.
Oh my god, no.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Okay.
I was gonna be like, no, I just filled a giant ass doobie.
A doobie like that.
That'd be so sad.
I literally just expanded my doobie too.
But it's okay, I got it.
Oh my gosh, she's gonna use that just as I.
Okay, I gotta get this guy out.
No, no, where is it?
Top or bottom?
Okay, oh my god, are you serious?
Okay, that's fine.
I didn't need that.
I did not need it.
Okay, this is actually less harder than...
And actually, this is...
Okay, why was Mint's ability so goddamn strong?
Compared to, like, doobie.
Like, nerf her.
I demand another nerf.
I ought...
She is level 2.
Nerf her or give me her ability.
Doki has spoken.
She nerfed to the ground.
Nerf her so she becomes out of meta.
Get rid of the meta.
Let's see it.
All right.
Got the knife.
Only I can be.
Yeah, exactly.
Only I can be the most OP character.
It's literally my game.
Like...
Alright, where is that?
Wait, that's fine.
I just need it.
Alright, uh...
I am the title of the character.
Excuse me.
Uh...
So, technically, I should be allowed to be the strongest character.
The doki has spoken.
Alright, where is it?
If it's...
Oh, my God.
Of course, it's...
the top.
Oh my god, wait, it combined itself.
Wait, why did it combine?
I thought I was supposed to make it smaller.
Alright.
Okay, that was my pop.
Or unless like, did she pop or did I pop it?
I'm gonna get rid of these just in case.
Alright, that's fine.
There was nothing over on that side anyway.
So that worked out for me.
If I get rid of this, I can have more of the mints around this side.
Oh my god, this one is...
See, this level is so much easier.
Okay, nice.
The iframes, it worked.
And then grab all the small mints together.
And then we can combine all the big dokees together after that.
the dragon.
These look like they look like bread.
Or like, are they supposed to be slime?
I guess they're supposed to be slime.
Oh no, I just I just saw her.
We gotta do this fast.
It's okay, the eye frames.
Oh, it's okay.
It's at the top.
We got the eye frames.
Alright, nice.
Oops.
Now I'm gonna pop that.
I wonder what's done.
Alright, you dead now.
What?
You're still alive?
You're supposed to be dead now.
Or is it because is so my turn?
Please, Doki, she's dead!
No!
We don't stop!
Take me to Doki Pop Island!
Alright, there you go.
Nice.
Victory, no mercy.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna ground... Well, How are my doki-pop skills?
Are you convinced?
Is Saikuno?
Oh.
Fine.
You really did improve since the last time we played doki-pop.
But don't blame me.
You can't handle doki-pop island.
Yeah, I just got a random invite from Saikuno for a game.
And I was like, what?
I don't even have this game on my Steam.
Like, relax.
But before you know it, the train will be filled with souvenirs.
Why do you even want to go so badly?
Why do I want to go?
Bruh, I'm sure you'll figure it out soon.
Of course I will.
I didn't receive like a Discord DM.
I just got a random seaman, but yeah.
It was just out of nowhere.
It was nice to invite me.
It just felt like it was just out of nowhere.
Thanks for the ride, Divi.
See you soon.
Good luck.
All right, now where was I?
Where are we going?
Temple is.
Oh, hey, Chibi.
It's my daughter.
I was going to say my son.
Chibi-Doki.
My son.
What the hell?
Is that a child?
Wait, Chibi, is that you?
It's my child.
Who's Chibi?
Why are you looking at me like that?
Is there something on my face?
Hey, don't leave me alone.
my god i'll be back i'm just gonna get some milk real quick her head is like two times the size of my head but yet it's so empty uh are we there yet nope are we there yet nope don't talk to me or my son yet again yes mostly uh like creature uh at least we know she floats you know Like,
if we chuck her in the water, she'll, like, the buoyancy of her head will allow her to be alive.
Two hours of exploring later.
God damn it.
Not this type of forest.
No, it's because her head is filled with air.
Are you there yet?
Hey, Chibi, what's that over there?
What?
All right, now what should I do?
Joki, you bit...
I can't believe you've done this.
She's asleep, huh?
I don't think you'll mind if I sneak these into her pockets.
Ah!
Oh, you're back.
Yes, I'm fucking back, asshole.
Language, Cheeby.
All right.
What are you even doing on this island?
To help.
Yes.
I'm a magical girl, duh.
I can manifest anywhere I want.
And you see me need the help from me.
Yep.
Oh, you're really helping me?
Thanks.
Yeah, I'm helping you.
Okay, then.
Lead the way.
Crap, I don't know what the hell to go either.
This wasn't an agreement.
Random direction it is.
This way.
Three hours later.
Out of all the directions, I lead her to the temple!
Hey, oh yeah, there's a lot, Chibi.
Okay, all I have to do is make sure she doesn't find...
I found a door!
Ah!
Oh, wait, stop!
Hey, what's wrong?
You can't go in.
It's too dangerous.
Oh, nah, I'll be fine.
You shouldn't be worried about yourself.
What an excuse you got for me, huh?
Can you explain what this is about, too?
You knew?
Of course I knew.
Since when?
That's for you to know, for me to know and you to find out.
You weren't asleep?
What should I do now?
Frick it.
Come at me, bish.
Does she not?
Does she actually swear?
I feel like, I don't know.
Chibi's skill converts up to eight random dokey pops on screen into a derpy dokey pop that does less damage when popped.
Make sure to look closely when chaining so you don't mix up.
What the hell?
Okay.
Okay, like, but I still have to pop them, right?
I guess, like, if I...
My mix is...
Mixes with it.
Um...
Oh, she does?
Okay.
I feel like...
I don't hear her swear that much.
But maybe it's because of...
My swearing...
I swear so much that anyone that swears less than me...
I don't register it.
Like...
It's just like...
I feel like...
No, or maybe because, like, I swear so much...
that, like, when someone else swears, it's just, like, daily conversation in general.
Like, I just don't notice, recognizes it anymore.
Okay, there it is.
I'll just pop.
Oh, I can't even pop it.
I mean, like, what do I...
I can't really do anything about it.
I'll just pop.
Oh, my God.
I have to... I have to wait for her to pop it, I guess.
Oh, my God!
How much more do you wanted she has so many okay it does half anyway so it doesn't matter to me
okay more or less like a lot i'm just gonna add all of these together first don't you there okay that's fine there's just so many oh my god she just takes up all my pops like i don't know what to do she's as she has overtaken them all like she's actually she's taken up all of it
okay there you go i'll add them for you and then you can pop it yourself
okay uh oh my god i'm like trying to figure out where where hers starts and where mine begin okay there's that oh my god please please get them out of here please take your child out of here I can't do anything about your child
okay oh my god there's more uh okay there now you'll pop it right there we go oh my god are you okay all right it's fine yo it's just all of that okay like i need her to like get it out of here there you go you can pop this yourself
I'll pop this and then there you go please don't turn this I said don't turn it I had one simple instruction
God it's so it generates so fast too oops all cheebies please oh thank God okay I I have to say, please.
Alright, now I can cut this.
Okay.
Here we go.
Alright.
I can't do anything.
She just...
It's just all her.
I'm like, I can't.
Please pop it.
Get them out of here.
It's just all cheebies.
all right uh there you go oh
my god okay that's fine i got that oh it just disappeared what happened to it what it's gone like what happened to it it just disappeared she was there
okay i'll get my stuff out of here before she overtakes them again Oh, please don't turn.
Just please.
I said don't turn into cheebies.
All right.
We got this.
And then.
There we go.
I did it.
Her head has laughed.
I was like, where did she go?
Did she disappear?
Oh, are you so cute?
strong hey you're pretty strong too i am yep no one's ever told me before not even my dad thank you all right well let's continue on word chibi because i am your dad i'm still not proud of you
that's tookie that's took
Oh, hey, it's my tomato drying.
It's a dragon god?
I'm not sure.
The dragon god?
Wait a second.
This isn't a dragon god.
This is the doki-pop god.
Wait, am I going to fight myself?
fight the tomato is this a temple or place where the doki pop god is seated there has to be a relic why did the paper feed me here
mint doki of course she can't do her job right
sorry boss what are you doing here isn't it obvious i'm trying to gain more power power that's right i'm going to gain the power to become the dokey pop champion and once i've become the champion i finally get my ticket the vvip meaning degree executive uh pro deluxe ticket went through all the trouble for something like that you don't need power to shut up you're the last person i want to hear that from you say i don't know your tricks i bet you're gonna snatch this relic the moment i look away i won't let you get your hands on it oh my god please don't talk about the fighter again he didn't do like a hot fix right now never right now welcome care to have some tea um no i think i'll pass suit yourself quick nerfer like I let the toky,
release the toky patch.
Look, I came here because you said you helped me beat toky and get those tickets.
Why don't you relax yourself, Miss Mint?
One thing at a time.
We have a common enemy, Miss Mint.
And I see potential to you.
Enemy, she's just my opponent.
That's not that serious.
Enemy are important.
that point is that if your friend loses I win and you win your suspicions are valid miss mint I promise you can trust me sure I can I've been acting weird since the first time we met understandable to show you how genuine I am I will give you a taste of that power you crave.
Let's say, as a gift of trust.
There's a mirror where that came from.
And as I said, as long as you're on my side, I'm on yours.
Teal?
But that's cheating.
Dokey Pop is supposed to be a game of skill.
A game of skill.
Since when is that case for any competition?
I'm not going to do that.
You're being too naive, Miss Mint.
Come, take a look.
Is that Doki?
Where is she going?
To Doki Pop Island.
Our destination.
Oh my god, he is Lord Palpatine.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
I knew he was going to backstab me.
Yes, on the island is a relic that has the power of the ancient Toki Pop God.
You say the one who wields the relic wields the power of the Toki Pop God.
The unlimited power.
Toki, I can't believe she will resort to something like that.
Pop has never been a game about skill, Miss Mint.
So, will you join me?
Okay, but first we need to stop Joki from getting the relic.
Don't worry about it.
I got it covered.
Oh, there's Shibi.
Hmm.
If you say so.
Then deal.
Bro, I feel like obviously he's the more evil one.
He's wearing a fucking hood!
You've gone far enough.
I can't let you through, Doki.
Wait a minute, where are you talking?
Prepare yourself, Doki bird!
Okay, wait.
Okay, this... this is not fair.
Bro, I said nerf her.
Alright, it's the same skill.
Guys, what happened to nerfing her?
Why am I fighting her again?
I thought we had a deal with my devs.
What happened to our agreement?
Okay.
I'm just gonna make this first.
Oh my gosh, she popped it.
Oh, you whore.
Okay, uh.
I knew, no, I swear to God, I swear, okay, there you go.
Uh...
I can't really do anything.
I just pop this for now.
I can do that and then pop these two.
Oh!
Fuck!
Okay.
That's fine.
I'll use this.
Do a little chop chop.
And then do that.
And then chop chop!
Where are the whiffs?
God damn it.
okay that's not big enough how's that not big enough okay try and get these guys out of here
okay oh my god i'll get this one out of here where it's over okay oh she popped to herself okay that's good i was gonna freak out i was gonna me like are you fucking kidding me I'm I worked so hard get that out of here if I pop all of this up there you go oh my god she's so strong I got rid of that oh
my God I'm using like 30% of my brain right now I'm actually like trying so hard to figure this out I swear to God please I lose oh thank God you pop yourself bitch it's all according to plan I can't do I'm like pronouncing that with the most like American accent ever you can't stop me
Okay.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Are you serious?
That was on her!
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh my god, it's just...
Please.
No!
It's fine.
I don't need it.
Oh my god, I need it.
No!
I'm trying to figure I can't believe it I wasn't I was I didn't mean to pop it
Oh my god I need more midheads I actually need more midheads I need to get rid of all these other ones
Oh my god Oh my god This is good This is good Oh my god This is good.
We're slowly getting them out of here.
Please just give me more midheads.
Oh my god.
I accidentally wasn't supposed to pop that.
I need to build up more.
I didn't realize I had to build up more heads.
Oh, this is not looking so well.
This is not.
We're not okay.
We are not okay.
I need more heads.
I need more.
I need more midheads.
Okay Oh my god.
Thank god.
Oh my god.
Okay.
There you go.
All right.
This is not okay.
This is actually not okay right now.
We are not okay.
We are absent.
No!
That is fair!
Why did I click this
abide?
I couldn't click!
Did you not?
see it did you not see it there was a bug there was a bug okay guys there was did you not see that bug it shrank okay
uh all
right um
it's just there no no you can't say that the wrist have just showed up.
It just showed up.
It was not supposed to shrink yet.
Are you fucking kidding me?
She popped it.
That wasn't her to pop.
It was property of dokeybird.
We need popping these.
She keeps popping them before I can get it to the whips.
She just keeps popping it.
This is illegal.
I demand to see my lawyer.
Where is it?
Alright.
Here we go.
God damn, I accidentally clicked.
I wasn't supposed to click that.
Okay, there you go.
Um.
Oh my god.
It's not fair.
There you go.
We got rid of one of the wisp.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Just try and send as many out of here as possible so I can pop that.
Oh my god.
Literally that I just made.
Okay.
It's fine.
We got rid of him.
It's okay.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
Oh,
I gotta get these guys out of here.
There we go.
I'm fine.
How does she have so much HP?
I don't understand.
This is like, it feels so illegal.
Okay.
Oh my god, that doesn't pop it.
That should have been a pop.
What?
Okay, I'm like looking at it by size.
Like, I know, like, I'm fucking it up by just looking at it based off of size.
Wait, all the whisper gun.
What happened to them?
No questions asked.
No, I shouldn't ask any questions.
I'll take what I can get.
I don't know what happened to them, but that's fine.
I don't care enough to know.
Okay.
Um, I don't think we're making it, guys.
I think we gotta say our final prayers today.
Alright.
Guys.
Guys, we might not even, I don't think we're beating this game tonight.
does you release the nerf the dokey patch if i lose to her in the next in this next fight i swear to god i don't see a dokey patch we're not finishing hashtag nerf mintha i ain't skipping i demand i will hold this game hostage patch I will I will hold this game hostage I I demand my patch it's so traumatic all right am I doing something wrong okay what am I doing wrong other than not popping the mintos yes
There's no way I'm doing something wrong, right?
Nah.
Alright, there we go.
Nah, I don't think so.
It's not me.
It's this...
It's this patch.
It's not me.
It can't be me.
Oh, I forgot the knife.
It's not me, it's her.
Yeah.
Oh my god, wait, I can do this.
We got rid of that.
I'll get rid of this first.
I can put this in here.
And then she can burst that if she wants to.
There we go.
Okay.
I have knife soon.
Oh, my God.
Of course she fucking comes in here.
Oh, wait, it's gone.
Nice.
That's right.
Be gone, you witch.
Be gone.
Christ compels you.
Okay.
Alright.
Knife tab.
Nice.
all right we got rid of this oh
my god I hope she doesn't steal my points that's my fear okay we got this there we go I prepared okay I was not prepared jokes on me I was not I want to pop this actually so I can grab this in here really that doesn't count
all right oh my how much more how much more do you want
all right okay that should be big enough thank god get these get them out of here oh my god she's does she does so much damage!
It should be illegal!
Like, someone call the cops!
Yeah, I'm gonna steal this.
I have a feeling I'm not gonna... It'll pop that anyway.
There you go.
I got rid of that, at least.
Get them out of here.
Okay.
There's a lot of whiz down there, so this should be enough to get rid of half of that.
Alright, stop my knife.
I'm gonna steal this.
Alright, there we go.
Come.
There you go.
Alright, I don't need the dirty patch.
I'm good.
I- I'm just that much of a- I don't need the dirty patch, guys.
JK.
JK, I'm okay now.
I'm okay.
Grr.
Hmm.
I can't believe my plan worked flawlessly.
The power of Doki Pop-Kan is now mine.
Huh?
No, it was you.
You betrayed me?
Do you really think that I'll give you this power that easily?
Huh, naive mis-meant.
with this no one will ever underestimate me anymore so it's like mid brian griffin and i'm like the rest of the family who can't understand what the fuck he's saying like oh my god he's naked now donkey abber doge surprise but why why you dare ask why for the longest time I've been under your shadow.
Always being underestimated.
Like I was just a silly dog.
You didn't know any better.
That didn't know any better.
At first I accepted it.
But as time moved on.
I began to feel as though I amounted to nothing.
And then all I see is like.
Ro, ro, ro, ro, ro, ro, ro, ro.
I realize nothing will ever change.
Or the way things stand now.
No.
I cannot accept that fate.
You know, oh, I can hear him.
I can understand him now.
You don't amount to nothing.
You matter to me.
Next time we meet, you'll see what I truly am capable of.
The dough strikes back.
No, don't!
Ah!
Shit!
Dad, you can't contain the dokeypop guide.
There you go.
I'm underestimating me again.
Dad, stop!
If you keep going, you'll die!
Shut your mouth.
Trap.
I'll prove you wrong.
Let's try out my newfound powers, shall we?
Oh my god, I fight literal god.
Alright.
A dokey bob god will drain your HP and spawn in minions that lock.
So you have a stroke rate.
Is that a real word?
Not N...
What?
near what that seems what is that it's real nail atrophy donkey pop stroke change i was like am i having a stroke right now like it's a very common word who from one country like Oh my god, please don't cancel me if it's like actually a common word in a country that I'm ignorant about.
I'm just ignorant, guys.
If it is actually a common word in a certain country, and I just did, I'm sorry.
Don't cancel me.
Try to make the locked doki pops bigger by popping pieces near them or use your skill to destroy the minions.
Wait, what?
All right, here you go.
Um, okay, I have to pop pieces near it.
I use that word.
How do you not know that word, dokey?
I use it every day.
I mean, I'm the ignorant one.
Already?
Oh, my God!
My dokey bomb!
Bro!
What?
Okay, this might not be fair.
Guys, do I even win this?
Oh, I got to pop one.
Don't
think I'm beating guys.
Um, did you want to lock another one?
I got
the fight back.
Ow!
I think I'm...
Wait, I think I...
actually locked me he can't do a move and i can't do a move i got softlocked how did you break the game alan thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i think i got some i know how to beat a guy
i did it
guys the game broke
Guys, wait.
Wait, the key, wait.
Wait, I broke the game.
I wasn't supposed to beat God.
I don't think, I don't think I was supposed to beat God.
Oh, no.
Where I could get back there.
I could get back to, I would consider an alternative career in game QA.
Thank you for the super chat, Rice.
Thank you.
Guys, I know what to do.
Alan, how did you break the game?
I don't know.
What did I do?
Thank you for the super chat, Alan.
I don't know what I did.
They didn't expect you to beat the guy.
Alright, I'm back.
I'm back.
Guys, I know how to beat a god.
Watch this.
I did it.
Oh, that was too easy.
Like taking candy from a baby.
You're so strong.
The power of the doki-pop god.
Huh?
I can't move.
Help me!
It's still a lot.
Yeah, script is a lot.
Oh my god.
What happened?
I know.
Oh my god, flashbang.
Even that, even the afterlife is creepy.
Oh, it's the feather!
The creepy old man gave me a piece of his hair!
The Grand Wizard!
Same.
Dragoon?
You... you died?
Ouch!
Such disrespect.
I have not died yet, foolish young master, and neither have you.
Then where are we?
A passageway between time, space, and spirit.
A source of it all.
A place where we manifest ourselves.
That's why.
We are able to connect.
Huh?
Young Master, I was called upon for a reason.
What could possibly diminish the Young Master's smile?
I think I disappointed a close friend.
Young Master, remember what I told you last time?
About how you're wanting me to use Joki Pop to connect people?
I am glad.
Young Master, listen to my words.
What about it?
Doki-pop, in one way or another, is a form of art.
And art is a form of language.
Within Doki-pop, there is communication.
Where there is communication, there is connection.
Yes, communication about defeating each other for sure.
Young Master, I request you to look further beyond the veil.
What do you feel while at this very moment?
moment.
Remember all the times we have sparred all the things you've been through in every connection.
Every you see it, young master?
Every time you did an action, there was a reaction.
Oh, like a chain reaction.
Each action and reaction are a dance between the souls that I predict.
Okay, it was this bullshit that you guys wrote in the script?
like are you just bullshitting like each action and reaction are a dance between the souls that are participating action reaction action reaction all of them connect into a cohesive line he's just making it up on the fly eventually the line reaches its conclusion and then you realize it's not just the fight that you experience young master it's a conversation young master my request is for you to connect with others using the power of jokipop using the power of friendship oh my god friendship is magic now young master You have some unfinished business,
don't you?
Shall we bring you back?
This time with the power of friendship.
Thank you, Old Bird.
You're always welcome, young master.
Let him cook.
Jokey pop, God.
I challenge you to a fight as you wish.
All right.
Okay, maybe this time it won't be like as fucked up.
Maybe this time, like I could actually do something.
Okay, all right, he actually lets me fucking play the game.
All right, that's good.
I can actually exist in this game.
Thank God.
All right.
I'm glad I'm glad he lets me play it out
Big pop All right, use that net Boom
That's right, my pop
All right, pop pop Pop.
That should make a big one.
Excuse me, I swear you got it.
You locked this one.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, I got worried that he's going to lock that one.
He's like, I need that.
I need that to live.
Okay, that's good.
And then I can have this one too.
Oh,
please don't lock another one.
I'm gonna grab this just as I can.
Alright, I have a knife.
I kept the knife just for this.
Wait, what does it mean when it's red?
I forgot.
No!
What?
How did he get it?
This is a little bad.
Just a little bit.
Maybe a lot.
No, just a little bit, guys.
Just a little bit.
bad okay not not that bad it's just a tiny bad don't worry it's salvageable we can fix it we can fix it see i told you i told you we can fix it i'm neck to neck with god right now
what what happened what happened to my pop
that was mine like sometimes he just I blink it and then he just goes yoying
like he just connects it in front of me it's fucked up All right, next time.
All right, nice.
Oh, my God.
I can be the God, and then I will be the next God.
And then, and then it's timeout time.
Okay, that's fine.
I swear, even God was easier than me.
Like, what is this bullshit?
Okay, this is...
I demand a Doki patch right now.
I demand a patch.
God, the sequel.
Yeah.
Alright, we did it.
We beat God.
Become God, Doki.
You are amusing, Mortal.
It's been a long time since Mortal has last best in me.
Tell me, why do you doki-pop?
I doki-pop so I can connect with people.
Fascinating.
You've done very well, Miss doki-bird.
And such a fate should not go unrewarded.
But tell me, what is it that you desire?
Please leave my dog's body.
Well, I guess exploring is for another day.
Very well.
Wait, actually, no, no, stay in mind.
in my dog's body like then let you know you know you won't i feel like you'd be less of demanding for food i don't key it's dead don't you i'm sorry god what's walkies
it's because he's a brat
it's okay you're okay bro god was so kind and nice he was so he was he seemed like a good guy god what's food now thank you so much
also having god as a pet is pretty crazy i was like don't piss me don't piss me off
I've got on my side.
That can't be real dad.
That can't be the real dad.
He is apologizing.
Mr. Miffluffikins, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yay, I'm a winner.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Oh, here's that.
Aw.
I'm never trusting you again.
Wait.
Is it?
Okay, I was going to say.
Oh, here, Mint.
For me?
Aww!
There you go.
That'll be $100.
Yay!
We did it!
Thank you and congratulations again to the devs.
We're winning sixth place in the Doki Jabs.
So shout out to Zephysona, Sarmalia, Adino, Island, Katz, Boakyu, and Dino again!
Yay!
We did it, guys.
That was fun.
That was really fun.
I really enjoyed the story and the gameplay.
I thought it would be like a Suka game, a Suka, but it was like, you know, it was definitely not like Suka.
It was its own little mechanic and everything.
So huge shout out again to the Jokey Pop devs.
That was very, very fun.
Jokey Pop be there.
Had a great time.
Yay!
I do demand a Jokey Patch.
I'm the man of Joki patch right now take away mince abilities I want mince ability no give me two abilities I want her ability as well I am the main character uh but thank you again all right let's check out um game number two that got fifth place at the Joki Joki I am so greedy of course i am all right sulfur and feathers so let's see wsc hold left mouse button right button for the gunpowder barrel all right all right and here are the deserts right i think i downloaded the game let me double check i'm pretty sure i did this is what this game is that has its own little download let me see uh okay there you go sulfur and feathers all right extract all i got extract the game all right so far feathers run anyway did you guys hear at twitch con like um apparently someone doubt like some of the PCs at twitch con had like what is it called like those things that like controls your PCs and stuff i don't remember what it's called but it happened on string on some of the like people who are
doing like we're streaming at twitch con or we're doing like uh twitch rivals and stuff they had like uh what are they called what like that it wasn't like malware but something that could like control like the pc and stuff yeah i don't know what the is it called malware like yeah and then it was like accessing the browser and everything and like typing shit in their browser and stuff remote desktop yeah i think is that what it's called yeah remote access yeah so some of the PCs had remote access downloaded for some reason and then um and then um like live on stream it like tat like it tad out of like a gate someone like people's games and then opening browsers and just start typing random shit in their browsers i don't remember it was like some fucking it was like it was crazy yeah yeah a lot of people's accounts are at risk with that too i thought that was the first time i've heard about it happening at twitch con i was actually at a land.
This is the first time I've heard about it at a fucking land event.
Yeah, it runs scripts and stuff.
I don't know if you guys heard about it.
I thought about it because, like, I was thinking about it because when I, like, it like came in my head, because when I was like, when I was like, right, you know when, uh, when you open a dot ex and they're like, uh, do you really want to run this game?
I was like, yep, run anyway.
it's not even the first time this really this is the first time i've seen it happen um that like it showed up on my twitter feed for me it was the first time i've heard about it because you would think after you think if it did happen the previous twitch con like they'll make sure to check the pc to make sure there's no malware or like remote access installed i don't know i feel like you checked that if it has happened before in the previous twitch guide all right sofa and feathers on me but maybe i'm expecting a bit too much no it was like multiple pcs it wasn't even just one pc because it happened to like happened to lulu lovely and it happened to a random like fortnite player that was playing a tournament which was fucking crazy because it happened on tournament like during a tournament too yeah
like the PCs were compromised one day dad was feeling underappreciated you had to change that with a call no don't cancel me yeah she was playing a tournament and then like her game all tabbed and opened a browser and started typing some random like a script started typing some random url url on stream while it was happening we have a call-up post of course you won't believe the treat situation oh no it's toky bird finally over i gotta find this channel delete it and the dragons were in the no why believe her guys what happened to believing her what happened okay wait All right,
new sound guy.
Newly promoted sound guy.
The hashtag TokeyBrit is over Friday.
Wait, hold on to set.
Oh, shit.
Wait, how do I set?
Oh, my.
Okay, I could just explode.
Oh, wait.
I hurt myself.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, oh, that's cool.
We don't hear anything.
Okay, do you hear anything now?
It's very quiet, though, to be fair.
I believe that.
Okay, I'll turn up.
Oh, you guys hear that now?
Personal best, playtester's best.
Oh my god, oops.
Give me a sec.
Wait, where did it go?
Oh, there you go.
Guys, I'm killing you for your own good because you did it.
Oh my god, is he holding a gun?
Okay, let me...
Alright, oops.
Alright.
That's fine.
Wait, which one?
Oh, it's so...
Oh, it's because that one's out of steel.
It's because they didn't believe me.
So I gotta take them out.
It's on them.
Oh, my God.
They have dynamites.
They're like, for that.
You know, it's like, for dokey.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I don't have a lot of HP right now.
No!
Okay, it's fine.
We got him.
Oh, my God.
He has a sniper.
What the fuck do?
Okay.
That's fine.
He has to wind up.
Here we go.
All right.
You guys don't need to know my HP.
It's okay.
You guys don't need to know how much my HP is.
All right.
See, everything is okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
I have the power of dynamite.
The power of... Oh, shh.
The power of dynamite.
Oh my god, you keep respawning?
Is it... Everything is fine.
Yeah, she's... What?
Oh, no, no, no.
I'm 2 HP now.
Am I?
Can I get past you?
No, that's... Okay, nice.
Wait, is that?
Okay, I thought that was the sky.
okay now i'm one hp now jk i'm two hp now that's cool the crows aren't my health wait i do it oh i could have shot that oops where do i oh it's here that's cool that the hp system is
oh okay okay missed bitch that's right if you go for the king make sure you don't miss i don't know it's a very famous quote in the overwatch discourse right now
this we don't know um it was oh shit oh shit okay sorry i gotta focus hashtag real it's fine nice got you now wait i'll just wait here and then okay are you serious okay nice that's fine that's fine that's fine oh my god you sent me so far back okay
chain reaction all right it's fine i got my hp back too they didn't And you did say to not miss.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's like, oh, my God.
I, oh, my, okay.
I keep accidentally setting myself.
I'm actually blowing myself up.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, I'm out of cover.
I have cover.
There you go.
What?
How do you live?
Okay, I have one HP.
All right.
Everything's fine.
As long as I don't get hit.
Oh, wait.
I have three HP.
JK, I can't read.
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, you can't do anything without your gun.
That's fucking right.
Oh, oh.
Can't do anything.
You gotta reload.
Now that I know you can't do anything if you don't have a gun.
That's right.
What you gotta do now?
Huh?
That's fucking right.
I think I've hurt myself more than you guys have hurt me.
Wait, what?
Oh, nice.
Ah!
I'm okay.
There's some heals here.
There's heals.
Oh my god, you're not shooting back.
It's good.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
We go up.
Got you now, Dragoons.
No one cancels me but me.
Wait, am I doing anything?
I am not.
Give me a sec.
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta...
I gotta figure this out.
There we go.
Oh no, oh no, oh no.
I'm trying to put it here.
wait am i oh my god i'm 1 hp what am i missing bro your bullet the bullet what am i oh my god how far am i okay that's okay it's not that far it's okay it's not that far
okay i'll get you out of here and then i don't think you're gonna chase me anyway Oh, oh god.
It's okay.
It's just one HP.
It's just two HP.
I can grab this.
I'm literally full HP.
Okay.
That's okay.
Never mind.
That's three.
It's okay.
I figured it out.
Watch this.
I didn't figure it out.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
I figured it out.
out guys don't worry look at this look at that i told you i told you i think i don't know why i did but i figured it out she did in fact figured it out i made it let me stand in a in one line oh oh shit oh shit he doesn't know he's so stupid he doesn't see me all right there you go oh wait where did it all come from oh my god it was a trap it was a trap
okay it's okay it's fine that's fucking right i'm coming for you you think just because you have high ground that you're safe no one is safe i think it here.
How do I get over there?
Oh, it's this way.
Why you pop our pig, bro?
It was an ambush.
Who would have... Oh my god.
I'll just...
Stupid.
That's right.
Can't do shit.
You should have popped up after I went down.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Alright, see?
It's fine.
Everything was fine in the end.
Just gotta walk this way now.
There's more.
There's so much more.
Okay.
Wait, what is he doing over there?
Oh, shit!
Oh!
That was my birds!
Wait, how the fuck did I get hit?
How did I get hit?
It's okay.
I gotta.
Oh, cat shooting me.
That's right.
Oh my god, there's two of them.
But it's okay.
I have this to guide me.
That's why I'm coming over.
Get out of here.
Nobody's canceling me today.
But how do I set this up?
Whoops.
Well, I could have done it without blowing myself up, but that works too.
That...
Oh, bring it up overall a little bit.
All right.
I brought it up.
There we go.
Ah, that's right.
Cage by your own dynamite.
Just as smart as me.
Free kill.
Okay.
Got you now.
Oh, no.
Oh, I can aim up.
That's good.
That's good to know.
Oh, my God.
That was like 20 of them.
Alright.
How many snipers are there?
It's fine.
Let's get out of this.
Oh, my God.
There's so many bullets.
It's like, it's like Toho.
It's like Toho.
I'm trying my best.
I'm shimmying.
I'm dodging.
I'm doing snake maneuvers.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
Rehealth.
Oh, shit.
All right, we go down.
Wait, do we go down?
Oh, my God.
We let you grow up to be that big.
Oh, no, that's big daddy right there.
God, look how fucking big you are.
Bro, you've been eating some protein.
What were you eating?
He ate his weed.
He drank his milk, guys.
See, this is what happens when you start drinking milk.
Where do I go?
okay i assume it's oh it's right here all right it's time to kill him i know he did nothing but like i don't like how he looks he's too big hey what he's just standing there bro just chilling oh it's right here oh shit bro is literally vibing oh
shit oh my god i'm stuck in the corner it's okay i have one hp and i dream yay we did it all right that personal best oh wait why did i forgive him he literally canceled me he is not allowed on the bed after that he's standing there meddling simply thank you again congratulations to all the does here congratulations he's no no no he he cancelled I got shot at this is what you did do the one treat it was one treat you won't believe the treat situation dad got his treat you are
The uncancelled Doki part.
The cancelled Doki party is over now.
She gave the treat.
All is forgiven.
Hashtag I stand with dad.
Bro, I can't believe that Doki game was real.
You actually broke one part of the...
Oh, was it the part where like the...
Big Goon didn't fit and fight back.
Was that it?
Like, he just stood there medicinally and watched me slowly kill him.
Was that the part where it wasn't supposed to be broken?
Yeah, he was supposed to fire cannons.
Yay!
I won.
Okay, that made sense.
I was going to be like, wow, he's just standing there, literally.
Like, he's just taking it.
Like, I take those.
do how do you beat every dude I killed an innocent man today and two out of three for breaking the final boss classic toky anyway congratulations congratulations to the developers for feathers and so fair um for fifth place yay congratulations all right we are gonna try the fourth place game now the Mario Maker style game from what the judges told me all right let's see
let me grab it now Okay,
it is called
Dokey Mint Do I have to download?
Oh, I have this downloaded.
Okay, so the king that won the fourth place It's called Dokey Mint Save the Golden Dragon believe is there information on the devs down here uh i believe it should be in the oh the author is dracorus i don't know if that's the only dev that worked on this uh but let me maybe it'll have the credit the full credits in the game but yes apparently it's like a mario maker type style of game so that's pretty interesting i'm not very good at making doing mario maker levels because i feel like making like good platform levels like it's it's like its own little Skill to have.
Because you have to make a level that's like really...
That are like really creative as well.
And that makes it fun.
And fun to play.
And I don't know if I can make it fun to play.
For myself.
Oh, so you have to make it so that it's beatable.
Okay, beat the level by platforming.
Okay, so I have to make it so that I can beat the level.
Okay.
That sounds easy enough.
I can fix that.
it all right let's do goky immense saves the golden dragon um all right more info
oh oh it's like 8-bit music too wow that's cute okay let me it's fix the full screen All right, while the music is playing I gotta go pee.
I'll be right back.
I didn't see the credits here, too
I am back.
Uh, Rice, Allen, Piripo, Bight, thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um nsd thank you for gifting a ship thank you thank you uh lower the sound a little bit i got you bro don't worry all right all right oh shit this is all made by one guy oh my god that's you're very talented bro i don't even try the game yet but like the fact that you did this all by yourself congratulations um and then i guess the fonts are
level select the final goon okay here okay so how does okay so what do they do quit level reset switch mode oh wait okay but like oh wait you can kill me oh Okay, what if I put it here?
Okay.
Oh, okay, I understand.
Wait.
Wait, I understand now.
Okay.
Here.
And all I have to do is...
If I shoot that...
There you go.
Oh!
I have one bullet.
I understand.
Alright.
Oh, I have two bullets.
Okay, I understand.
Guys, I don't think she under...
No, I understand.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
I understand
Wait, wait, wait, I figured it out though.
I figured it out watch this
Okay, can I do that?
Okay, wait wait wait wait wait wait I do this and then Oh I can jump on it, but I can't face...
Okay, I understand, though.
Just so creative, by the way.
Okay.
Oh, I...
Okay, there you go.
I bet you I'm actually making it harder for myself.
And then...
Phew!
And I got my bullet back, bitch.
How do I get back up?
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait a minute.
How do I get up there?
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
I jumped here.
And then...
I do that?
and then i jump here and then wait i'll do this okay i figured it out watch this okay why watch this
oh my okay but i figured i got it i got it though
oh okay wait wait but i got it though
He's got to time it perfectly.
Please, please for the love of God.
The game doesn't get it.
It's not me.
Wait, wait.
I got it.
Right here.
There we go.
See, I told you.
I told you I got it.
Yeah.
What?
Okay.
Maybe I put it here.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
I got it though.
See?
Look.
Look at that.
Boom!
I told you.
I got it.
I told you guys Dragoon get I told you I got it Okay I hit her And then I grab the bullet and do a cool As jump right here And then And I jump here And then I use this Wish as a platform I go boom Boom and then I don't Boom And then Okay, let's just test this out real fast.
Okay, that...
Apparently, that was actually not it.
Um...
Uh...
Okay, give me a sec.
Okay.
Um...
Right...
Oh, okay, wait.
Wait a minute.
Give me a sec.
Let me...
Okay, that does nothing.
That's good to know.
That's...
Okay, I...
Okay, wait, wait, I figured it out.
Oh my god, I knew it.
Okay.
Alright, I figured it out, though.
I was on top of it.
I don't understand.
Um...
So I don't know what to do after...
Okay.
Where would you go?
No, I can't move.
I can only move him.
Trick shot?
Where, though?
Okay, wait.
I figured it out.
Oh
It's gonna be sick.
I got it.
It'll be a sick.
I-
Oh my god, I'm getting- I need to get past the- I need to get past the first stage and it's just-
Maybe it's here
Oh my god, okay.
Maybe I move him here.
I just gotta master this jump.
I just gotta master this.
I figured it out.
When I master this jump, it's okay.
There you go.
Goodbye.
Where do I go after that?
Okay, never mind.
I thought I was so smart with that.
I guess never mind.
I was like, oh, it floats.
There's another side of the brick.
Where?
I don't think I can do any better.
Wait.
Oh my god, you're so right.
Okay.
Wait, is it a rocket jump?
It was not a rocket jump.
It was not a ride.
Oh my god.
I wish I could just shoot this.
Ow!
Okay, add chat.
Okay, that's it.
Add chat.
Add.
Why?
Under the bricks.
Before that.
brick what what the fuck this brick how use the TNT oh you can do that wait where the fuck is it wait right oh my god wait oh my god I'm so smart Okay,
wait, okay, I jump from here, and then I go here.
I jump here.
Does that destroy...
That should destroy everything.
It should destroy all of that.
But then, like, what do I do from here, though?
Oh, I shoot that, and then this could destroy all of this.
Oh, I see.
I see.
I'm brainstorming.
Okay, I...
I just gotta figure this part out first.
Is the dev here right now?
Is the dev here right?
I would like to know if the developer is here right now.
I just have a little patch note for you.
A little suggestion.
A little suggestion for your game.
It's fine.
Oh my god.
Please!
I'm holding space!
Oh my god, I swear to god, I'm holding space.
I swear to god, I'm not fucking with you.
I'm holding space.
Okay, that's fine.
It's not, it's fine.
five okay
it's okay it's okay it's so five I master the first jump okay okay I met I master the first jump though there we go now what oh shit what the fuck is going on
It's fine.
I mastered the first jump.
And I mastered all jumps.
There we go.
One, two, three.
it's fine it's fine i i i know how to do the jump snap there you go
one two three i did it i it's oh my god so fucking easy levels for babe oh my god okay this is a bait okay what are these blocks these what are these spooky blocks what do these spooky blocks mean first try
what the fuck does the spooky block mean
jumped into one and see Oh my god.
Trick shot below.
Why is it spooky?
Oh, the button!
Oh my god.
How many times can I trick shot this?
What is that perfect angle?
Guys, I don't...
Surely, surely if I shoot enough...
Okay.
Oh my god.
How do I trickshot this?
Wait.
I don't know.
Okay, wait.
How did I do it?
Where did it go, was it?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, I think that was it.
Oh my god, that was actually it.
No!
Wait.
There you go.
Oh, please!
Okay, okay, okay.
There you go.
You guys have to figure out the trick shot, though.
Okay, don't.
Don't do it.
You know you want to.
Oh, you're right.
That spooky block.
You're so right.
Okay.
And I'll do another trick shot right here.
Because I ran out of ammo.
Oh my god, wait.
JK, I still...
All right.
There you go.
All right, we got this.
Okay.
How do we do this?
Oh, I can shoot from Belize.
Hello?
Guys, I don't...
I ran out of ammo.
I...
Maybe you have blocks.
Me have blocks.
No way.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god, please.
Please!
It'll work eventually, guys.
There we go.
Okay, how do we do this?
How do we do this?
Oh my god, it's like this?
Guys, it was not like that.
Guys, guys, please.
Guys, what is the geometry?
What is the geometry?
Do I jump?
Eyeball it.
What?
another block.
Oh, I have another ghost block.
Look at that.
Okay, where do I put this ghost guy?
Where do I put this little ghosty?
I don't know.
I'm just watching.
One spooky block above the middle pier?
This spooky little guy?
Right here?
Oh, wait.
I assume it's right here.
Yeah, okay.
We got this.
We figured it out.
Okay.
Oh god, okay.
All right.
Watch this.
Oh my god, it actually, one bullet in a dream.
Actual one bullet in a dream.
Oh my god.
That's the fucking bullet.
I told you.
I said, watch this.
Oh, calculate it.
Trigger happy tomatoes.
What the fuck do the tomatoes do?
What the fuck?
What do they do?
Why did you go left?
Oh!
Are you doing?
What?
Okay, I know what to do.
Why the fuck would I use spikes?
Wait.
What happens when it drops on the spike?
Oh!
That's fucked up.
That's really fucked up
There's nothing I can do It's timing Okay I think I can get rid of this And I'll put two spikes here That's gotta be it
Yeah There we go Like good luck Good luck to me Oh my god, this is so much worse.
Why?
Why did I?
This is so much worse.
This
Yeah, guys, I don't think that was the strat.
I
Um Welcome to hell We here Whoops
Maybe the timing won't be as bad.
Yeah, there's sort of...
I guess.
Oh.
Oh, I get it!
Okay, wait, wait, I understand.
And then...
Give me a sec.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I see.
Wait, I figured it out, though.
I don't know.
Okay.
But you guys see my vision, right?
You guys see it, right?
Oh, my God.
Every time.
okay that wasn't it okay that wasn't it apparently that what i i don't know i thought i thought it'd be different i really did thought it would be different but maybe not
got an idea I don't know how that happened okay
wait okay wait okay wait wait
just just let me cook okay
I'm not gonna live was that how do I live with that
how do you survive how
remove the other two spikes oh my god you're right where do the spikes go oh you're right oh my wait
but where but where
like here
yeah here okay it's slower now Okay, I made that a lot harder than it was supposed to be.
Oh, that's smart.
Okay.
I take back everything I was gonna say to you, Dev.
Okay, my timing is so off now that it's slower though.
Don't worry about it.
oh my god okay it's fine okay it's fine it's fine figuring it out though
here we gotta grab all the bullets
all right we got bullet what bullet three
oh my god it's fine
It's okay.
I just gotta make that one jump.
And then we got here.
Okay, I rushed a little too fast.
But it's okay.
I have this part down.
The back of my hand.
Figure it out.
Okay, I still figured it out.
jumped a little too early but i still figured it out it's still there
i made it down i just gotta go fast when i shouldn't have
okay that's fine god damn it
okay oh my god it was so close i was right there i was right there I Got the timing down Oh my god, I got the timing down for real now I
Okay, got focus here.
God fucking damn it.
God Just we restart Okay, I'm just rushing now.
Okay, slow and steady don't you slow and steady
Don't need a rush
all right are you serious are you fucking kidding me i nearly got jump it's just that jump it's like it's such a tight jump
put him okay oh my god i swear to go okay oh my
Nah, I have more time.
Let's go.
I just had to make that harder for myself.
I just had to.
Oh, my God.
I...
What do you mean?
I just need it, too.
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
We got this.
We got...
Okay.
The ghost of Doki Pass comes in to haunt me, but I got it.
Alright.
Okay.
That's okay, it's okay.
I just mistimed it, you know?
Everything was so fast.
And I have to take it slow now.
Now that I have access to slow.
I'm not used to it anymore.
No!
Okay.
I got
the trigger finger my trigger finger oh my god I'm not patient I think the judges are much more patient than me see you see this is why I didn't pick I didn't pick the the last three winners it would not have been I if I had played 200 138 games.
I would not have been past the first level.
I...
There we go.
Okay.
All right.
We got this.
Move that block to the left.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh my god, wait, did I make that harder for myself?
Oh my god, you mean I could have done that this entire time instead of making the tightest jump of my fucking life?
Okay, but it would have been so cool if I made it though.
But guys, it would have been so fucking cool if I made it.
That's...
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure this out.
out okay here we go
oh my god oh my god we did it and we still have two more two more levels okay
what the is going on
What?
I imagine.
Bro, the fuck is around with me.
It's like those two tomatoes.
Bro, what do I do?
Dude!
That's worse!
What the fuck?
Okay.
Let's not do that.
What the fuck?
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, guys, I don't think this is it.
Yep.
But what if I
Oh my god I was like But what if I make it stop No guys I can't make it stop I can't
Guys I don't know That does not look right That does not look right Okay Block them on the opposite.
How?
How the fuck do I block that?
Oh wait, I got an idea.
Okay, give me a sec.
I can't break it.
I thought I could.
I thought I could break it.
I have like one of each.
Put the dirt block in the middle.
middle like here guys this looks like absolute hell i don't know about this i that looks fucking terrible move it one block down on the tomato doesn't let you put anything on the tomato
no i can't i can't adjust it when it's moving
What the fuck do I do?
What is this hell's a hole?
How did my judge just beat this game?
There's no way.
I bet they asked the devs the answer.
There's no...
I refuse to believe they figured this out on their own.
I...
Can we create a pro-kidoki pro war for next year?
It feels necessary.
Block and button to stand on running down the oh my god wait okay no oh my god
that's why it's called the red herring
oh my god you okay okay it's a dev here now i do want to say something
Okay, I figured it out.
Oh, my God, I'm just stuck.
Just stuck.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
no don't you dude are you fucking okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay one two three one two three four five one two three four okay i make it
okay i make it
oh my god oh my god Why would you do this to me?
Why the fuck would you do this to me?
Fuck, do I get over there?
You jump.
Thank you.
Wow, okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
I just jumped.
Who would have thought?
I...
I just how do I get to the other side how how do I all I have is this like
this is what happens how do I shoot this block then what do I do I can't jump over there you
can place the activator above the button making the bridge as you fall down making it what the fuck what the fuck does any of that mean
but like what about that door block what do i do with this the
button and the activator for What the fuck are you talking about?
What?
I don't know.
What do I do?
Alan!
Oh, I beat this!
How do you beat it?
How?
You're so smart.
How did you do it?
Why do I get to the other side?
Right below the one you have?
How do I get to here?
I'll just go to hell right here.
This is...
End my life faster.
It's just...
It's just ended.
This was like the closest I got.
All you gotta do is beat the level to win.
Someone upload a recording right now
It's the dev, I'm sorry It's the dev in the chat, I need a note Is he in the chat, I need a note This is very important Is he in the chat right now
Alright, wait, alright Put your, okay Proceeder I you said you beat it for what was this solution post it in a tag right now post it in the tag right now I give up I I'm waiting someone posted in a bird cedar tag right now
Post it in a bird cedar tag right now That's it Four, fifth and sixth all get the same amount prize money.
I'm sorry.
You're going to sixth place.
I'm bumping the other people up.
It's the same prize money.
You're going to sixth place.
I'm sorry.
Four, fifth, fifth, and sixth.
You guys got moved up.
You guys, you got moved up.
Bro.
You just didn't do the thing.
You can't do that, Toki.
I am making an executive decision right now.
I'm in an insane overall.
That's so best.
You said there won't be biases.
I lied.
All right.
Okay, so I do this and then Oh my god
Okay, wait, where do I put the other button?
Oh my god Oh my god What do I think of this?
Okay, okay, okay I'm okay I'm okay mad because Okay, oh my god How is I supposed to know the fuck that I can't do that?
Okay
Alright, we did it I figured it out this level took me 25 minutes of late Because the levels got what?
How is I supposed to know you put two buttons together?
It cancels it out.
Alright, what is this level called?
What is this level called?
Okay, the final goon.
First try.
Burn out the thank you for the time.
Give the chips.
Thank you.
I wonder if there were more solutions.
Yes, Tokyo, you did such a thing.
Lulu Nemo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
All right, here we go.
What the fuck is this?
Okay.
Give me a second.
Why is this level so fucking big?
my god okay okay give me a second
oh my god
okay why is there why is there five bullets to pick up I'm sorry, duo.
Okay.
I just...
I have to be sure.
I have a...
Oh my god.
Okay.
I assume I have to block it, right?
Oh my god.
For God, he hurts me.
Okay.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Okay.
I don't know what I'm doing I
Okay, but what if I shoot it at the perfect angle And then it'll hit him And I just see him I have to hit him So he hits this Oh my god Place the ghost under the ghost Oh my, okay, it still didn't work
Oh my God, you whore.
You add to a whore.
Eventually.
I just gotta angle it correctly.
Oh!
Please.
Please give me a...
Alan!
I'm refreshing!
I'm doing call it dragon.
Call it dragon.
Alan, I need any dragon.
I demand the solution, right?
now.
If I don't get a solution, when I do a countdown of five, this game goes to sixth place.
I am making an executive order right now.
I'm giving a count of five.
And if I refresh and I don't see the solution, this game is going to sixth place and I'm bumping everyone up.
I, it wouldn't happen.
I am, this is a hostage situation.
This is...
Five, four, three, two, one.
All right, I'll give you, like, three more seconds.
I know a solution.
Use your brain.
Three.
I expected like a fucking picture by now.
To be fair, I did not try to do it.
You won't.
That's why I said thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
I literally assumed you guys would have posted it.
I was like, all right, that's it.
All right.
Executive order.
No negotiation.
All right.
Executive order.
Right now.
All right.
I think we're all stuck here with the power with the power of the executive order this game is now sixth place the fifth the last the previous fifth is I'm I'm sorry I you have successfully rage baited me and it's okay it's still the same prize money but I I just can't beat it I can't beat it I can't don't worry because she's just salty she's dumb anyway so the other games they're now four fifth this game is now sixth place and whose fault is that it's it just wasn't toky proof and because of that i had to make my executive order all right i'll do i'll try i'll try try one more time i don't think anyone has beat it you have forgot to doky improved this game.
I'll have to demote you.
A truly amazing game right here.
Zomber.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can do it.
I've given up.
I've lost all hope and humanity.
I...
I can't...
Just end me.
I wish I could just...
Oh, I...
Oh, the fucking whips can kill me, but I can't do it if I do this.
I...
Oh, my God.
Nice.
Okay, wait.
My executive order right here.
Wait.
Oops.
This is how...
This is how I'm ending things.
If I can't.
Please.
Oh, my God.
It was right there.
I could have ended right here.
I had the perfect angle Where it actually hits me
Alright I will This is how I will end the game There we go, there we go There we go D dragon Thank you, super chat Thank you, thank you in this moment.
Be great, sir, because your own skill shaped my head.
I just can't see it.
It's not joking.
What do I do?
Just just take me out and take me out.
I don't need to go take a super chat.
Thank you.
Ah, yes.
My new favorite manhwa the vtr follow made a game contest but somehow became a dictator oh my god wait oh wait never mind that was the old i thought someone fought i don't think anyone nobody has figured it out nobody has figured out this there's zero solutions at there's actually no solutions at all no one knows no one knows no one knows what to do
No one knows!
It's over.
You've successfully rage baited me.
You have won the award.
This game has become first place for me.
Thank you for the super.
chat thank you thank you all right i'm gonna call it here i i don't think i can i don't i'm not okay the thing is my mods my my mods and my judge panel they fucking finished this game yet i do not see a solution from them yet they are watching this stream right now and I don't even I'm not gonna record my voice back I was gonna they stayed up one of the head of this project stayed up because I told them I'll record my voice back later I so they stayed up thinking I would record my voice back later I'm not gonna do it anymore I'm not I'm not doing it today That's so petty That's right.
I demand the solution and then I'll record the voice back and then I'll record the voice Is this how you treat it?
I demand the solution Showing you the solution was not in the contract the map.
Don't keep these.
That's right.
You stay it up for nothing.
You...
We don't negotiate with Terris.
I don't know how to see it.
I don't know how to beat this level.
Sneaking like a real duchess.
The angry voice back.
That's, I know you're here.
You said you'd wake up.
You said you'd stay up.
When Doki loses, she makes sure we all lose.
But we're thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, actually, I think he passed out.
I think he didn't think I'd be streaming this long.
I don't see I don't see him in chat like I don't guess I don't see I guess I don't see oh wait no He's typing he's typing.
Okay, he's here.
He's here.
That's right All right show me the show me the solution Right now
You beat the I know you beat the game show me or you stayed up for Nothing.
$1.
It took me two hours over two months ago.
I crashed out so bad at this level and then you told me to give it fourth place?
What the?
You and the judges?
down at the last level and you're like fourth place fourth place right here at the point the donkey's gonna be there but tossing it is a good game wait no they're a buckler to solution
wait no they did it no they did they compared the crash down at the last level like the dark souls of toky champ poor place to make toky crash out god my blood pressure is not good right now my my blood pressure is not good right now for this i i could feel it
the dark souls of you we'll never know i guess we'll never know the solution chat we'll just never know
all right i'm gonna call it here i'm not recording the voice back i'm sorry you gotta wait you gotta wait tonight i'm fucking i'm taking a nap right after the stream is over i i'm taking you'll find the recording in the morning I'm so tired Please Toki,
please We are on You should have thought of that before putting it at fourth place And then not providing me the fucking solution
You should have thought of that before
Anyway Hey guys As always everybody Say hi Posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing if you stay up for me head to bed cuz you deserve it Hey guys, um Thank you all for participating in the doki jab.
I will definitely stream more Doki jab games in the future I had a lot of fun
I had a lot of fun And then somehow the fun stopped I don't know why, how that I don't know when that happened But at some point For some reason the fun stopped But I had a lot of fun Grumpy child toky Is one of the toky's of all time Thank you for the super chat Nexi,
thank you, thank you Anyway Anyway my to the my voice pack mod when you wake up you'll get the recording but I'm taking my nap time you know like when the child gets angry and you're like okay it's nap time it's my nap it's nap time hours now you gotta sleep the angry away you know like when a child gets a temper tantrum you put the child to sleep that's me right now anyway
anyway guys um i hope you all had fun watching i hope some you guys had fun that's all that matters i hope i hope you guys had fun um anyway make sure to watch the ending screen today because it got updated i'll see you guys next time everyone also it will okay it will make me happy if you you know there's the limited drop right now of um of the concert merch and we still i know i should i haven't tweeted out yet but i'll tweet it out when i wake up for my nap time um but um there is a limited drop of the concert merch that you can order right now because these are like it won't be restocked so after after it's all sold out it's gone forever because so yeah and get it right now guys whoa anyway I'm fucking taking a nap bye guys
Thank you.